[Applause]
you were
you were talking a little bit yesterday
about uh the morning routine
yeah yeah yeah yeah and now i've heard a
lot of people talk about morning routine
every one of these like books about like
billionaires they're like oh every
billionaire has like
the same morning routine um
and this is something that i really
appreciate about what you do is it it
becomes practical when you do it yeah
yeah
you know like they go every billionaire
is the same morning routine like they
wake up
you know they brush their teeth it's
like yeah poor people have that too
yeah i don't think that's the thing
making them a billionaire yeah
but what you were talking about was
brain state
yeah yeah so can you get into that a
little bit yeah i believe the treasure
we seek is hidden
in our in our routines and uh you know
and where we pick up these routines
probably when we're kids
or somewhere along the way that we
didn't sit down and design what would be
best
um i'm probably part to blame for that
there's a video
out there if you search billion or
morning routine
somebody took one of my interviews and
kind of click-baited it so it looks very
catchy and has seven million views
um i wouldn't say having spent some time
with some very wealthy individuals yeah
they they don't do all these things no
not at all but um yeah
my thing is if you want to win the day
you got to win that first hour of the
day
because there you want to get some
momentum right and so
my day some of the things to think about
first
my day starts the night before because
you really need to get a good night's
sleep and i don't know who i'm talking
to
but if you're hustling at the expense of
your sleep the challenge is you can't
cram if you're gonna run a marathon you
can't just
wait the night before and just you know
exercise seven hours that night
right or if somebody is gonna go you
know play play basketball
you know for a big game you can't just
cram the night before things certain
things take a natural process
and i would say um you know going to bed
uh maximize how's your sleep eh yeah
yeah it's okay i mean we have you know
these dogs kind of wake us up a little
bit but
i'm getting to sleep earlier i would say
seven hours a night maybe six seven
hours a night
do you feel rested when you wake up not
really yeah i mean i think that and and
people are watching this they're young
they could plow through it but it's just
important to have these
these habits early on when you can yeah
and nobody gets this perfect
right the goal is not perfection it's
just making some kind of progress what
is the right amount of sleep
so um and how do i stop peeing in the
middle of the night yeah
yeah does that count against my my rems
it could
yeah it certainly could affect your
sleep i would say it's not the quantity
of your sleep it really is
the quality you you know these like
sleep devices like aura ring and stuff
like that yeah as you sleep
so for it's the deep sleep and it's the
rem sleep the deep sleep is when you
repair your body the rem sleep
is where you restore your mind and so
it's not just the quality
some people get eight hours and they
still feel like
exhausted you know and so it's the
quality of the sleep so
um imagine we can't manage anything you
can't measure so i would recommend
people kind of do a sleep study stuff
like that
my sleep i don't talk about this a lot
but um
for five years i slept 90 minutes a
night yeah it was it was rough
and this was in the really the height of
my my career
and uh you know maybe two hours total
and i would wake
and i found out i was misdiagnosed i had
a sleep test
and i have um severe sleep apnea and i
don't know if anyone knows what that is
but it's a breathing disorder
yeah and uh usually for fat people right
yeah because what happens is you gain
weight especially in the neck area it
can it restricts your your airflow and
so you wake up
not be able to breathe and for me it
wasn't a weight issue it's just a
genetic thing i found out later my
parents have sleep apnea both and my
brother and my sister also
do and i would stop breathing 200
and like 20 times a night and each time
was at least a count of 10 seconds so
imagine
so the doctor at ucla was like no wonder
you're in such bad shape it's like
somebody coming in
200 times a night and putting a pillow
on your face yeah and you're waking up
suffocating i couldn't breathe and i
would use a cpap breathing device yeah
yeah you know a dental device which is
real sexy
night babe yeah yeah darth vader for the
rest of the day exactly
and so i would do all these things and
still move it and eventually
i was um i was having breakfast with um
with larry king and he's like a big role
model like where we live in la and
and you know one of my mentors and he
brought me literally walked me into his
uh
ent to get analyzed and i actually
got diagnosed properly and we went to
the head of
ucla surgery and they they did this
surgery on me where they took out my
tonsils my uvula my soft palate
extremely painful
to create more place uh you know a place
where i could breathe
yeah and that helped a lot so i went
from there to about four or five hours
and that was life-changing for me you
know i don't know how you slept for 90
minutes
you know what it was years it's and
that's why i wrote this book part of it
and there's a whole area of sleep that i
really became like you know like
read every book talk to every every
expert on the subject yeah
but but when you don't sleep and i'm
just i don't know who i'm talking to
right now who's struggling with this
yeah you know it impairs everything like
your temperament your feelings your
relationship
you know you how you could think and
focus how you can remember things
so a few sleep tips what i do the night
before my evening routine
is i want to make sure your brain loves
continuity and consistency so going to
bed at the same time waking up the same
time even on the weekends
is a big score i know it's not easy yeah
all right so nothing about
success and performance is easy i'm not
saying it's easy but i'm just saying
it's worth it
right and so going to bed at the same
time
having it dark because you know with
modern day conveniences
you know with lighting and screens we
fool our brain there's the blue light in
your screens for your devices
that fool your brain to thinking it's
still daylight and so it doesn't produce
the melatonin and help you relax
and go to sleep you know the other
trigger besides light is
temperature you know back when your
hunter gathered you knew to go to sleep
because it
the lighting dipped and so did the
temperature but in controlled
environments
you know it doesn't get cold and so
making your your room a little colder
will help you sleep get that
restorative sleep you kind of hibernate
you know yeah yeah and so uh
yeah and uh and before i go to bed one
of the best things you could do
is go through just your day you know
people can't remember things
following day or what you like what you
did that day okay so there's something
called episodic memory an episodic
memory is very useful because
you notice even with with the pandemic
it's really exasperated this
where days blended together i could keep
going no no no
so relatable yeah there was a time where
you couldn't even ask me what day it was
yep
we just been working straight through i
don't know if it was a tuesday it was
thursday especially you're not going out
there's nothing on tv exactly there's
nothing like positioning your week
that's so true
if you're not going to the movies not
going out to restaurants or clubs or
whatever
peg the week to these different events
and they weren't happening
because you don't have those distinctive
things that stand out in your memory so
they all blend for days right yeah yeah
yeah and so
that's your episodic memory and so what
you could do is just spend
as you go to bed take three minutes and
so there's no such thing as a good or
bad memory
and and some people think uh yeah i
actually there's a train memory and an
untrained memory and what are those
so so there's no such thing as good or
bad memory when people say have a bad
memory it's just
you haven't trained your memory because
we weren't taught how to do that and one
of the things you could do a simple
exercise that anyone could do
is at the end of the night when you're
lying in bed just take three minutes
close your eyes and just review your day
right what did what did you put on what
were you wearing what did you eat for
breakfast
who what calls did you make right and
that helps to train your brain
so you start remember what a lot of
people don't remember what what happened
you know that day or what they talked to
yeah and these the thing the reason why
memory is so important
is because you know i lost when i was
going through these
learning challenges and my my
grandmother was my
my primary caregiver right because my
parents always had all these jobs and
stuff and
and so when i was going through my
challenges she um
at five and six started showing the
signs of dementia and alzheimer's
yeah and if anyone you know my heart
goes out to you if anyone has
pops yeah yeah all right so you know
what i'm talking about like
she would call me by my dad's name uh
she would say something
she just said 45 seconds ago yeah and
when people lose their memory it feels
like they're
they lose who they are so while we teach
people to remember facts figures
formulas whatever it's really about
remembering your life
remembering your loved ones remembering
your lessons right those those special
moments but um that really affected me
early on
and that's why you know i dedicated you
know the
all the proceeds of the book to
alzheimer's research and children's
education because we're so passionate
about that
but that just broke my heart and it just
made me think about
you know what's good for the for the
brain and if you're not sleeping that
could
really add they say your genetics
because i'm concerned because that's you
know genetic
your genetics loads the gun right but
your lifestyle is what fires it and so
that's why it's so important
to to to treat yourself well and
especially your brain because your brain
controls everything right you want to
change you change your brain you change
your life you change your brain you
change
your world so so the night before you
reflect on the day
i go through the day for a few minutes
and it's just hey what are some events
that happened today i just want to
lobby after a week of doing it
you start getting more and more clarity
you start remembering the things
you